Russia has warned that the UK's decision
to supply long-range cruise missiles to
Ukraine is an extremely hostile step
which represents a serious escalation in
the war well the British government
confirmed yesterday that it was donating
Storm Shadow weapon systems to give Kiev
the best chance of Defending itself
against invading Russian forces our
political correspondent Mario Aurora is
in Westminster a Mario strong statement
from the Kremlin against her the UK's
decision to send these weapons to
Ukraine
exactly Simon and I think realistically
it's not going to come as a massive
surprise to Westminster it kind of fits
in with the rhetoric we've heard from
Russia in previous times when the UK has
sent weapons to Ukraine as well so it's
not that it's surprising but nonetheless
it does it just got to speak to the
delicacy of supplying weapons to Ukraine
when it comes to International diplomacy
and when it comes to how and when and
exactly what is supplied to Ukraine you
can see those images on your screen of
of that Storm Shadow missiles they're
actually uh long range air-launched
cruise missiles and they've got an
improved accuracy which is one of the
things that Russia is concerned about
now the real kind of political issue
here is we know Ben Wallace the defense
secretary yesterday said in the chamber
that these weapons will be used within
Ukrainian Sovereign Sovereign territory
that reduces the risk of any escalation
essentially which is something that
Russia say they are concerned about and
obviously the international community in
general would be concerned about and
then also a couple of hours ago
president zielinski of Ukraine has also
tweeted thanking Rishi sunak for
supplying those weapons and also so that
they discussed further defense
cooperation as well so the ties
obviously between the UK and Ukraine
still very very close but it's always
quite politically tricky in terms of
supplying these weapons to Ukraine